ce qui est vrai ce qui est sûr c'est la
première partie c'est l'accident
c'est l'hospitalisation c'est les
victimes les trois victimes ça c'est sûr
après il est mis en examen le chef
d'incubation enfin le chef de
l'appelation de la mise en examen et
risque d'évoluer
juridiquement dans le temps en fonction
des critères de la vitesse du véhicule
et de d'un certain nombre de choses
et j'ai envie de vous dire que les
choses commencent à se calmer
il y a eu une décision judiciaire
puisque il a été placé sous
bracelet électronique
le juge de la liberté de la détention à
privilégier de le soigner plutôt que de
l'enfermer dans une prison
et donc les choses étaient en train de
s'apaiser lorsque samedi
un homme de 28 ans
appelle alors il appelle pas le service
de police qui est en charge de l'enquête
il fait le 17 d'accord et là il
s'explique au téléphone il dit je suis
un ami ou un ancien ami il est pas si
ancien que ça parce qu'ils sont vu le 14
janvier
je suis un ami de Pierre Palmade j'ai
des révélations à faire
il y a
des des choses horribles concernant
il détient des vidéos
pédo pornographiques et il aurait
enfin il se vante en tout cas il dit
qu'il a eu des relations avec des
enfants qu'il avait des enfants un
enfant de 7 ans et un enfant de 9 ans à
cette disposition donc évidemment cet
individu va être convoqué à la brigade
de protection des mineurs
deuxième là c'est à Paris donc ça fait
un troisième service de police qui
s'occupe de Pierre Palmade comment ça
faire beaucoup
cet homme est entendu il explique que le
14 janvier dernier il était en compagnie
de Pierre Palmade que Pierre Palmade lui
aurait dit que pour assouvir ses
fantasmes il avait à sa disposition la
possibilité d'avoir deux enfants un de 7
et un 9 et il lui aurait montré sur son
téléphone portable le début d'un film
pélope
et les choses s'arrêtent là évidemment
le parquet de Paris
ouvre immédiatement une information en
urgence saisit la brigade de protection
des mineurs et ils vont aller faire une
perquisition au domicile parisien de
Pierre Palmade qui est dans le 3e
arrondissement et là ils vont saisir
tout ce qui est disque dur ordinateur
enfin tout ce qu'ils peuvent trouver et
d'ailleurs on peut s'étonner que c'est
pas été fait avant dans le cadre de
l'affaire de stup mais bon
j'allais y venir ah oui on a aucune
certitude de la véracité des faits on a
eu dans cette affaire d'ailleurs un type
qui s'était
désigné dénoncé comme étant le passager
de la voiture et on s'est aperçu très
rapidement que ce n'était pas vrai
alors est-ce que
on est sur un gros mythomane il
n'importe quoi c'est une possibilité
quelqu'un qui veut nuire à Pierre
Palmade c'est aussi une possibilité bien
sûr
après peut-être que Pierre Palmade a dit
des choses dans un état second sans
aller jusqu'au bout des choses et sans
avoir de
passage à l'acte enfin toutes les
possibilités sont encore ouvertes
aujourd'hui mais cela est-ce que là
c'est pas aussi je vous dis la vérité un
acharnement voilà on l'a tous dit ici ce
qui a fait ce qu'il a fait c'est
inadmissible tout le monde l'a dit tous
ces amis mais là ce qu'il y a pas une
sorte d'acharnement et là n'importe qui
va appeler l'info va être prise partout
parce que là aujourd'hui je vous dis le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'on ne sait
même pas si c'est un faux est vérifié ou
pas moi j'ai vu plein de gens
aujourd'hui
dans l'après-midi tout le monde m'a dit
c'est quoi cette histoire de Pierre
Palmade qui aurait des images
pédopornographiques rien n'a été prouvé
rien n'est on sait rien mais tout le
monde dans la tête des gens maintenant
c'est aussi ça y est il aurait des
images pédopornographiques oui bien sûr
parce que les gens se demandent aussi
pourquoi si cette soirée a eu lieu le 14
janvier pourquoi est-ce que curieusement
l'homme a attendu après l'accident pour
se manifester donc c'est pour ça Cyril
que les enquêteurs veulent vraiment
savoir exactement ce qui s'est passé il
y a une première perquisition dans le 3e
arrondissement aujourd'hui une deuxième
perquisition ils sont retournés à la
maison de Pierre Palmade à Célia en
bière pour saisir de nouveau du matériel
alors tous les ordinateurs les écrans
ils ont les discret téléphone ils ont
pris le téléphone aussi de l'homme qui
s'est manifesté prénommé Patrick alors
vérifier et la vidéo aurait été envoyé à
certaines rédactions absolument alors
exactement cette histoire alors
effectivement dès le début l'homme a dit
je ne suis pas seul il y aurait un autre
homme qui est aujourd'hui ce serait
manifesté également et certains médias
donc un média dont on n'a pas le nom là
ce soir à cette heure-là aurait eu cette
vidéo voilà deux possiblement encore je
mets plein de guillemets Pierre Palmade
regardant ça pourrait être ça sur la
vidéo pierre palmat qui regarde lui-même
une vidéo pédopornographique donc voilà
où on en est pour le moment il y a pas
de charge retenu il y a une enquête et
il est très possible il est même
probable que Pierre Palmade soit entendu
très bientôt pour cette affaire alors il
y a d'autres choses vous allez voir
qu'on va vous montrer parce qu'il y a
plein de choses qui sont sorties aussi
mais juste on voudrait voir la dernière
sortie de Pierre Palmade elle a été
dévoilée hier et a été tourné vendredi
soir voilà c'est la vidéo qui pose
question ces dernières heures celle où
l'on voit Pierre Palmade pour la
dernière fois regardez
voici l'image la plus récente d'un
Pierre Palmade dans la tourmente
vendredi soir c'est par une porte
dérobée qui les sorties du tribunal de
Melun mis en examen pour homicide et
blessures involontaires aggravées par
l'usage de stupéfiants
alors cette sortie de Pierre Palmade a
fait beaucoup parler pour des tas de
raisons il sort tout seul il prend un
taxi donc il va très certainement vers
le contrôle judiciaire et son attitude
aussi beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux
sociaux on dit et on avait sur des
réseaux sociaux j'ai vu une photo passée
moi voilà on voyait il y a plein de
trucs qui sortent là
donc c'est vrai que cette vidéo a fait
beaucoup parler parce que certaines
personnes l'ont trouvé entre guillemets
un peu décontracté etc bon c'est un
homme seul qui va se rendre à son
contrôle judiciaire personnellement je
ne vois pas dans son attitude de
scandale à dénoncé voilà je vous le dis
très clairement
il y a des moments où il peut sortir
bah il y a juste le chauffeur du taxi il
y a pas de policier qui l'accompagne
j'ai pas vu le j'ai pas vu de policier
qui l'accompagnait
c'est la question que je pose il va à
son contrôle judiciaire faut s'il y va
pas il va aller en prison donc c'est lui
qui dit vous m'emmenez à mon contrôle
judiciaire il y a pas quelqu'un qui
l'emmène non mais il est pas en
détention
où il peut c'est pas c'est comme ça
il est où la pierre Palmade alors c'est
quoi l'histoire bien Palmade il est dans
un hôpital à Villejuif
qui va direct au contrôle judiciaire
donc il sort de l'hôpital il dit à mon
contrôle judiciaire et rentre à
l'hôpital
je pense que j'ai pas le détail de son
contrôle judiciaire mais si il fait
surtout avec les caméras à l'extérieur
c'est qu'il peut le faire bien sûr
surtout s'il va pour son contrôle
judiciaire parce que si on viole le
contrôle judiciaire c'est la case prison
immédiatement c'est ça donc il a pas à
mon avis dans les prochains jours il va
se passer quoi il peut aller en prison
un prochain jour il va rester à
l'hôpital il y a eu un appel de la
décision de de JLD ça va venir là dans
le d'ici la fin de la semaine
le parquet de Melun ce sera vendredi 24
février à 9h voilà avec examiné le
parquet de Melun souhaite
qu'il soit incarcéré
donc le le degré au-dessus de ce qu'il a
aujourd'hui
donc on verra bien
dira son avocat ce que dira le JLD et
quelle sera la décision sur les
perquisitions il y a eu quoi de alors
matériel informatique ordinateur c'est
perquisition c'est suite à l'appel
absolument donc il y aurait pas de
perquisition non dans le domicile du 3e
arrondissement c'est suite à l'appeler
au possible vidéo pédopornographique et
la nouvelle perquisition à son domicile
de Cély-en-Bière également lié à ça
c'est à dire que la première fois ils
avaient pris tout ce qui concernait la
première affaire exactement exactement
et là sur la troisième affaire ils ont
saisi le matériel les écrans la
téléphonie pour essayer de trouver la
trace de ces fameuses hypothétiques
vidéos voilà c'est elles existent si
elles existent exactement alors qu'en
est-il pour les deux les deux qui
avaient fui la voiture parce que on
entend des versions incroyable ils ont
dit que ils savaient même pas qu'ils
étaient même pas rendu compte qu'il y
avait un accidenté
est-ce qu'on l'a la vocation BFM est-ce
qu'on peut le voir s'il vous plaît merci
il n'a pas pris la fuite c'est que
l'autre passager lui a dit on y va
suis-moi et il a suivi je suis comme je
l'ai dit je suis même pas sûr que mon
client ait eu conscience qu'il y avait
un accident et quand bien même en
extrapolant il l'aurait su il aurait pas
pu apporter les secours nécessaires il a
pas fuir ses responsabilités on était
sur une route qui était sombre on était
sur une route qui est totalement sombre
sans éclairage mon client voyait tout
noir avec des acouphènes et non sur le
moment il n'a absolument pas vu qu'il y
avait eu un accident il était vraiment
totalement
débousses déboussolé donc
il l'a su un peu plus tard
qu'effectivement il y avait eu un
accident alors la flemme également que
son client n'était pas du tout un escort
boy et qu'il y avait pas de relation
tarifé entre regardez
votre client est-il ce qu'on appelle un
escort boy
absolument pas c'est je l'ai répété il y
a quelques instants un excès de lent ami
de Monsieur Palmade
ils avaient d'excellentes relations de
confiance
l'un et l'autre parlait énormément entre
eux
et c'est tout en fait non il y avait pas
de relation tarifée ce genre de choses
et il y a eu un témoignage ce week-end
c'est le chauffeur de taxi qui a
transporté les fuyards juste après
l'accident qui les a emmenés sur Paris
écouter ce qui s'est passé dans la
voiture
c'était chelou dans la voiture il me dit
écoutez on va viser
ici et voilà ils m'ont dit merci merci
au revoir alors ils avaient chacun un
sac ils ont gardé avec eux-mêmes ils ont
pas voulu mettre dans le coffre par
moments
tous les voyages ils se sont pas parlé
le grand black il était tout le trajet
sur son téléphone mais par contre
l'autre il avait l'air d'être fatigué un
peu choqué il était voilà dans la
voiture détendu voilà avec des soleils
en pleine nuit en fait une grille ils
ont pris une douche ils sont sans
rafraîchis ce sont ils ont changé leurs
habits tout ça en fait ils sont montés
frais dans la voiture entre guillemets
pas du tout l'alcool ça sentait pas
voilà quelque chose bizarre
pour la déclaration de l'avocate les
mots me manquent pour les commenter mais
moi j'en ai un c'est honteux
comment peut-on soutenir un tel système
de défense
quand on a vu les images des véhicules
ou alors ils étaient
complètement défoncé mais enfin même
défoncé enfin ils ont ils ont réussi à
partir ils faisaient quand même très
structurés et ils ont réussi à retrouver
la maison de de Pierre Palmade ils ont
ramassé leurs affaires ils ont appelé un
taxi sur le compte de Pierre Palmade
donc ils sont pas totalement désorientés
et dire nier l'évidence et dire que on
n'a pas remarqué qu'il y avait un
accident j'ai envie de vous dire que
c'est un petit peu fauteuil du monde
alors donc il y a encore deux trois
enquêtes j'ai dit Pierre palmates des
tensions d'image peu d'eau
pornographiques maintenant c'est alors
c'est ça le la nouvelle enquête la
nouvelle enquête donc voilà deuxième
enquête homicide des blessures
involontaires bien sûr et troisième
enquête trafic de drogue ça ça vient de
tomber aussi donc trafic de drogue le
parquet de Melun ouvert une enquête
supplémentaire pour trafic de drogue
compte tenu du dépistage positif de
Pierre Palmade et des deux qui ont
reconnu avoir consommé des stupéfiants
alors toute la problématique au niveau
de la drogue c'est d'où vient la drogue
qui a acheté la drogue qui a fourni la
drogue pour cette soirée est-ce que un
réseau parce que c'est ça la vraie
question est-ce qu'un réseau serait au
cœur de ça c'est ce que maintenant les
enquêteurs veulent savoir parce que oui
on peut acheter des des seringues mais
de là à acheter des drogues de synthèse
qui aurait été consommées jusqu'à 30
minutes avant l'accident de la cocaïne
sans doute en quantité assez importante
d'où ça vient comment s'est fourni donc
là les enquêteurs elle a même dit que
son client de se droguer par un avocate
oui ça c'est l'avocat de dépasser et
juste pour répondre à Michel on peut les
critiquer les deux passagers mais la
justice ne les a pas mis en examen c'est
exactement le statut de témoins donc ils
ont ils ont à mon avis l'intérêt de
leurs avocats c'est d'appuyer là-dessus
de dire voyez ils n'y sont pour rien
c'est un jeu une stratégie d'avocat mais
pour le moment ils ne sont pas mis en
examen et pourquoi moi si je fais un
accident avec mon camion et que il y a
un accident que je vois un accident je
par mois je m'arrête pas pourquoi moi
m'accuse de non-assistance à personne en
danger et que je dois répondre à un
tribunal pourquoi on n'aimait pas devant
le tribunal les deux qui sont sauvés ils
auraient peut-être plus sauvé des gens
ça va arriver d'accord
donc il arrive il va il faut pas dire
aux gens qui nous regardent mais tu peux
te sauver moi je suis avec ça ça va
arriver
donc on sait pas où il va être libre et
le deuxième qui a été condamné à un an
ouais c'est ça le deuxième attendez on
oublie un léger détail c'est que le
deuxième a été condamné à un an de
prison avec sursis probatoire il ne
devait pas parmi ses contraintes prendre
entrée en contact avec Pierre Palmade on
le retrouve dans la voiture et on le
lâche dans la nature on marche sur la
tête moi je trouve que cette histoire on
découvre chaque jour à quel point la
justice marche sur la tête vraiment
hallucinant il y a une grosse zone
d'ombre sur cette affaire que j'aimerais
quand même qu'on lève ce soir parce que
personne n'en parle et c'est vrai que il
y a quand même un énorme problème autour
de l'affaire perd pas le match je suis
désolé de vous le dire c'est un moment
il y a des deux autres personnes chez
Pierre Palmade c'est eux qui ont dû
nettoyer tout ce qu'il y avait à
nettoyer et eux ça essaie on en parle
c'est pas qui c'est on en parle pas
personne n'en parle c'est inexiste pas
non mais c'est vrai c'est l'Homère pas
totale donc et c'est vrai que on sait
tous sur tout le monde voilà c'est ça
alors qu'elle n'existe même plus on en
parle même plus en fait il y a une
couille dans le potage il peut y avoir
possibilité
[Rires]
on est d'accord il y a un gros problème
sur ça oui mais comment il y a un
problème
Gilles alors
combien de personnes maintenant certains
voilà on dit deux personnes une des
avocats disait finalement il n'aurait
peut-être été la major la majorité du
temps que trois après la grosse question
Cyril qu'on peut qu'on doit aborder
c'est qui était ces personnes
ont-ils nettoyé ont-ils été accompagné
dans le nettoyage et
sont-ils
protégés c'est-à-dire
sont-ils assez connu pour qu'on n'ait
pas envie de les identifier voilà la
question que tout le monde se pose et
j'ai pas voulu poser parce que est-ce
que est-ce que d'histoire non mais c'est
ça est-ce que est-ce que il y aurait des
gens
fils de ou des personnalités telles
qu'elles seraient protégées
est-ce que vous avez entendu quelque
chose on a entendu que ça pourrait être
des fils de
en même temps aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué dans une procédure
judiciaire de cacher un ou deux
individus
on a vu des affaires criminelles
importantes ou des gens connus étaient
figurés et ils ont été
confondus entendus et accessoirement
écroués donc faut vraiment que ça soit
quelqu'un de très très très important
mais j'ai du mal à y croire si vous
voulez bien sûr alors peut-être qu'au
départ on a une mauvaise information et
qu'effectivement
et Pierre Palmade et que les autres
n'ont jamais existé où ils sont
peut-être venus avant ils étaient déjà
repartis c'est possible mais j'ai du mal
à imaginer aujourd'hui en 2023
service de police
la police de Melun le commissariat de
Melun et maintenant la brigade de
protection des mineurs qui fait partie
de la préfecture de police de Paris donc
après en soi ils ont le droit d'être
dans la maison s'ils ont rien fait mais
faut pas bien sûr nettoyer
et on les voit pas après quand le taxi
vient les chercher
euh il aurait profité du temps vraiment
juste tu voulais dire un truc sur
l'affaire Palma moi je voudrais dire
quelque chose qui peut choquer tout le
monde mais
moi je soigne les gens enfin je suis psy
j'ai toutes les personnes et je leur
apporte mon aide je défends les surdoués
vous allez me dire ça n'a rien à voir
mais on interne des gens on les oblige à
des soins en les confondant surdoué
bipolaire pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont des gens qui sont malades qu'on
a besoin de soigner avant l'accident
pourquoi est-ce qu'on prend pas alors
maintenant j'ai entendu qu'il va y avoir
des punitions pour ceux qui roulent on
va en parler demain
en tout cas pourquoi les personnes qui
sont en danger il était en danger il a
même dit que c'est pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on soigne pas ce pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a pas un soin un soin
obligatoire
que j'ai envie qu'on soit là pour
l'instant moi c'est ceux qui sont
victimes de l'accident je te jure
je sais après je vais te dire un moment
il faut savoir aussi prendre sa vie en
main il faut les camions
est-ce qu'on pense que tu dis mais
c'était comme moi toi tu as de la peine
pour tout le monde et 25 ans de sauver
tout le monde et c'est de guérir tout le
monde à un moment c'est c'est ça devient
compliqué